let's talk about the LA mayor's race
here before the end of the show because
you brought up a great point we have a
great new mayor who or candidate
yeah Caruso uh Caruso and I I like this
guy because Caruso built the Americana
in Glendale which is a disgusting
outdoor mall where animals go and they
eat it to Cheesecake Factory but he's
gonna build one another version of it
exclusively for homeless people and let
them play in The Fountains and have fun
and [ __ ] wherever they want and I think
that's the move can you get up his ad
his advertisement oh yes yes they can't
get mad at us playing that no no no
record Chris
Rick Caruso he's going to be the new
mayor of Los Angeles because he is uh
he he's very good at building malls
so he's going to fix the problem because
the homeless crisis is really because
they don't have them all
I don't think he put it on YouTube but I
bet I could find out
thank you Ben you don't have to
Telegraph what you're doing you could
just deliver
um
but I like if he goes he's like the
problem is that they don't homeless
people don't have a mall of Their Own
give them a mall give them an outdoor
mall where they can
conduct their business
nobody goes around an anthropology
something's fun yeah something fun
clear everyone out of h m let them go in
there
here's an ad he's running called faith
family and community
think nobody can clean up La yes meet
Rick Caruso uh-oh lifelong Angelito
husband father grandson of immigrants
raised to put Faith Family and Community
First a lifelong Builder and job Creator
that's right we created the Southlands
most beloved community centers and he
always shares that success what are you
talking about
Americana is a Beloved Community Center
it's a corporate hellscape
it's a Beloved Community Center people
in Glendale don't know where to go yeah
I mean it's a big outdoor mall just the
community center
he hands out turkeys on Thanksgiving
like Frank Lucas Rick Caruso's a
lifelong Angelino
he's made billions of dollars Building
outdoor malls and now he's ready to
build one for the homeless
keep going Ben
giving Millions to provide health care
and a good education to kids in LA's
poorest neighborhoods and giving
tirelessly of himself first appointed by
Tom Bradley he served La under three
different Bears fought corruption and
waste and cut crime 30 I'm running for
mayor because the city we love is in a
state of emergency rampant homelessness
people living in fear for their safety
and politicians at City Hall just in it
for themselves my only special interest
is Los Angeles the city we love it's why
I work for a dollar a year and I won't
take a dime from special interest I'm a
ready together
I worked for a dollar a year I'm already
loaded
and I'm a little sick of this city
getting less comfortable for me and my
friends so I'm gonna work for a dollar a
year and we're gonna use direct energy
weapons on the homeless
you pay me dollar a year and I will have
the lap ballet PD out there with batons
every day it'll cost your taxpayers only
a dollar a year for me to vaporize
homeless people in the middle of the
night
so you can feel safe going to the
Americana in Glendale and get the
a [ __ ] herb crusted salmon at the
Cheesecake Factory for 48 dollars
I feel like the people in this don't
even know they're in a rickaroo so Eddie
just took photos of people
the city we love
finish this
we can clean up L.A read my action plan
at carusocan.com
Rick Caruso can clean up la
now get an interview with him up before
we get out of here because maybe I'm
making fun of this guy but
maybe maybe this guy's got a plan
because you've lived here forever tell
people about it real quick
uh it's a great place a lot of homeless
people well what's what are the problems
and he's going to handle it
look at this man
he's gonna fix it
Rick Caruso will work for a dollar
these [ __ ] what he's he's dumb
slogans I'll work for a dollar a year
why the dollar
just say you have to make something I
gotta
be able to go home and look at my wife
so I need at least a dollar a year
let's see what Maybe I'm Wrong let's see
Rick about sort of what separates you
because ultimately this is a job
interview right and people got to pick
who is the best person for this job you
have a different biography than most of
the other people
you're the most qualified person to lead
La when a lot of the people you're
running against have a lot more
experience in government
Factory let me first talk about it
on me which is an important question
that you've asked
um they've had a lot of opportunity
they've had Decades of Public Service to
get something done and they haven't they
failed and I just find it interesting
that you've got a group of people that
are tasked with making the city safe and
livable
and they've had a decade to get it done
they've failed but they want to raise
and a job promotion that wouldn't happen
anywhere else right and so if you think
they've done a good job I'm not your
candidate if you want more of the same
I'm not your candidate let me tell you
about recuruso I've worked hard I'm from
humble beginnings I love life I love
giving back and I've got a track record
of moving into a situation where there's
a serious problem or a crisis in fixing
it I came into cmpd it was last summer
at the Cheesecake Factory at the
Americana there was a crisis because one
of the chefs was drunk every day and he
was burning the chicken fingers and if
you know anything about the cheesecake
fact we got great chicken fingers in
there so what I did was I sent him to a
rehabilitation program and brought in
another Chef who is actually my deadbeat
cousin my deadbeat cousin came in there
and he actually did a great job but
that's the kind of experience I have
under a federal consent decree run by a
federal judge crime was spiking I
reformed LAPD hired Bill Bratton we
dropped crime by 30 percent that was a
crisis situation
as to step up at USC we turned USC
around with a lot of help from
leadership but that's a very different
Enterprise today this works the only
people committing crime in this city
will be the cops
if my plans
if my plan is enacted the only dangerous
people in this city will be the police
I want to restore La back to the rampart
PD days as we know the LAPD is a great
institution and I'm proud proud to I
reform them that involved telling them
hey hey do it quietly
I reformed the LAPD with Mike do it
quietly program
it's the uh might do it quickly
very success
where are we we encourage cops to behave
exactly as they were but quietly you
bust that guy's head in quietly I'll
make a big deal about everything
see the rest of this I'm you know what
this guy's I I'm starting to believe in
him
yeah he's good four years ago when I
took over his chair
and I have this passion about Los
Angeles and we're in a crisis that's
what it is let's say what it is and I've
got a track record
of being able to manage through a crisis
lead I'll hold myself accountable I'll
make tough decisions and I'm not looking
for another job I want to be mayor I
want to get a job done and go home I'm
not looking at making decisions through
a political lens to get reelected like
all of my other candidates who are
running are doing uh when you say USC
you were chairman of the Board of
Trustees at USC fight on so uh let's
talk about because we know the two
biggest issues right now you lead with
them in your campaignopolis
laughs
why don't we why don't we ever see the
face of the interviewer this is
incredibly distinctive if you've ever
seen an interview like this you don't
even see the face of the interviewer
I mean what is happening I guess Fox 11
only brought one cameras and why is he
being interviewed in a restaurant I
don't know it's like what's going on
all right keep going all right all right
I'm some of your critics point to the
fact that you supported George gascon
for district attorney do you regret that
and do you now support his uh recall
so I knew George when I was the
president of the police commission and
he was a deputy chief and he wanted to
be Chief I didn't make him chief he
wasn't ready for it at the time and I
hired Bill Bratton
now he left and became the chief at Mesa
Arizona that went up to San Francisco I
knew a very different George now what
happened to George on his journey from
Mesa to San Francisco that changed the
way he thought about fighting crime is
very different than where he was so
early in his campaign I did support him
he was a friend I knew him from from our
time to give LAPD once his campaign
started rolling out and I was hearing
about what his plans were I quickly
pivoted and I gave to ejaculation I gave
her a significant amount of money to
support her so I regret what George has
done and I think George either needs to
stand up and say the policies that I've
put into place are harming our
communities and I'm going to change them
or he should step down and if he doesn't
step down he should be recalled because
he is harming our communities and I
stand with Charlie Beck and I stand with
Bill Bratton that said the same thing
this was a different George than we all
knew when we worked at LAPD together I
don't know what's happened but clearly
he's got a change or he's got to go the
other big issue is homelessness yep
number one thing you're going to do
that's going to be different than the
people that have been in there so far
kill them day one declare a state of
emergency move the authority into the
mayor's office I'll be accountable to
fix it I'm going to build the smartest
team in the country to go fix the
problem we're going to go build
30 000 temporary beds we've got excess
land throughout the city that's declared
Surplus land
we're going to give people an option to
move into a clean safe place in a very
humane way give them the right services
that they need mental health physical
health but you don't get a choice to
stay on the street anymore
you have to draw a bright line that
we've got communities
whatever demographics you have to do is
you have to do the best finishes you
have to really do indoor outdoor living
because a lot of them are outdoor anyway
you have to do indoor outdoor living you
need large Windows lots of natural light
you need buildings with gyms you know we
need to move them into into luxury yeah
yeah so we're going to build all these
luxury units and if the homeless people
can't afford them we just sell them to
foreign billionaires
but the most important thing we're going
to give the homeless people the option
to get a job it pays a lot of money and
move into these units for eighteen
thousand dollars a month and if they
can't afford that we're going to just
get put these units on the market at
market value and uh we'll leave the home
is exactly where they are
laughs
that are severely impacted by
encampments you can't tolerate it
anymore when you say there's a
consequence what does that mean you're
arrested you probably are arrested if if
we give you a bed and we give you the
services and we clean you we feed you
and support you and I think there should
be retraining programs to get people
back on their feet they can get back on
their feet why then should we allow
people to live on the street good good
point and where do you draw that line
you can't and that's what's happened
with this problem everybody has been so
politically correct
in their mind whatever that means to
deal with it the problem has just gotten
larger let's talk about your place in
this race
um you live a very comfortable lifestyle
after working really hard and being very
successful in business that is the
American dream right but the average
American doesn't live your lifestyle the
average Los Angelino doesn't live your
lifestyle how do you relate to somebody
who's struggling to pay the bills
well let me tell you again I grew up
with immigrant parents from Italy that
lived in Boyle Heights and my
grandfather was a gardener and I
remember riding in his truck and I
remember a family that lived from
paycheck to paycheck there was always a
meal on the
tablet fascist
he was a supporter of Mussolini how do
you relate to the regular people my
father was in fashionist who supported
Mussolini they lived paycheck to
paycheck and he used to read books on
Hitler
so I know exactly what people in this
country are going through right now I
can relate to all of them
thank you so much